bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 le journal le point sur leur formation
l'actualité locale voici les titres que
nous allons développer en ce 2 septembre
plus de trois cent mille élèves du
public et du privé de retour à l'école
de la maternelle au lycée dans le
département les effectifs sont en hausse
pour cette rentrée sur fond de
réorganisation des rythmes nous ferons
le point avec notre invité jean michel
coignard le directeur académique et et
services de l'éducation nationale dans
le département alors que les élèves
reprennent les cours en coulisses
l'heure est à la polémique et valérie
pécresse principale opposante à jean
paul huchon le président de la région et
de france accuse ce dernier de ne pas
financer suffisamment lé lycée
si certains sites touristiques dans le
département en dresse un bon bilan de
cet été les activités extérieures ont en
revanche souffert du mauvais temps nous
faisons un point complet ce soir
l'actualité aujourd'hui à 2 septembre
c'est bien sur cette nouveauté et qu'ont
découvert les élèves les fameux été
happé l'étape comprenait les temps
d'activités périscolaires c'est l'autre
versant du réaménagement des horaires
d'école ces moments dégagé dans la
journée pour permettre aux élèves de
pratiquer un sport un loisir ou de
travailler leurs leçons avec des
animateurs compétents les villes sont
libres de proposer les activités de leur
choix
certaines font du zèle pour d'autres
c'est service minimum qu'on fait vos
enfants aujourd'hui dans ces fameux thé
ap réponse à la sortie des écoles de
guyancourt et de la verrière
micro-trottoir signer elodie moines et
william el bahia la bibliothèque ou
d'aller vers des jeux
polyvalent on pouvait rentrer à
l'intérieur comme des activités tous les
jours et on a joué bas au niveau de
l'organisation forcément la première
semaine
ben voilà c'est en est on favorise bas
plus à la sécurité que l'animation et
puis ça va se mettre en place au fur et
à mesure a offert mesure des jours où va
faire de l'informatique
peut-être à faire ainsi du jardinage 10
par des ordinateurs de la boxe et du
hockey des activités pour faire des
dessins sur internet
ben j'ai déjà du jardinage
je reçois ce soir jean michel coignard
bonsoir le directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale dans
le département des yvelines c'était la
rentrée ce matin pour vous également on
va évoquer les grands dossiers qui
attendent l'éducation nationale quels
sont les enjeux de cette année avec vous
mais tout d'abord cette question des
temps à des activités périscolaires
on constate qu'en fonction des communes
c'est un peu le grand écart certaines
proposent le strict minimum d'autres
proposent beaucoup vous ne vous dites
pas que l'éducation nationale qui ne
doit pas gérer ses temps ça dépend des
villes mais que l'éducation nationale
est passé à côté de quelque chose
il a fallu qu'elles soient plus
impliqués pour l'été ap vous avez raison
c'est leur compétence en l'état
de la réglementation en revanche je fais
tout de suite ajouter quelque chose de
points le premier c'est qu'on ait fait à
l'image du reportage au centre les
activités lorsqu'elles sont là
essentiellement sur les arts la culture
l'environnement la citoyenneté le
numérique
donc c'était présente dès le début ces
préoccupations le deuxième chose aussi
pour présenter un peu la rentrée sur 240
communes avec l'école c'est qu'on a reçu
presque 100 ans je crois qu'on est à 98
projets éducatifs territoriaux et dont
ces projets éducatifs territoriaux on
détaille les activités proposées par les
par les communes et là on retrouve en
effet un panel très large dans le cadre
des généralités que de données et pour
les communes qui font de la résistance
qui ne valent rien proposé pour marquer
leur désapprobation de cette réforme on
peut citer à la ville d'elancourt le
maire l'a dit et répété avant la rentrée
il n'y aura rien de proposer si ce n'est
de la garderie pour convenir aux emplois
du temps des parents la consigne était
passée auprès des enseignants aussi
censés vérifier sur le terrain
aujourd'hui c'est de la garderie
là vous dites waouh maire d'elancourt
par exemple on est sur autre chose je
pense qu'il ya des moments dans
l'histoire que ça va pas se faire en
trois jours je me souviens que la mairie
d'elancourt souhaitait développer des
activités numériques autour du numérique
entre midi et deux et peut-être le soir
donc bon les activités sont est pas mon
table tout de suite dans le contexte
dans lequel se situe la commune mais le
bon espoir que ces temps peut-être
bouger puis soient occupés de manière
nouvelle
on va écouter justice comme le maire
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous lui
parle même d'une mobilisation dans une
quinzaine de jours il fera le point avec
les maires membres de son collectif anti
réforme il ya 700 maires en tout qui
composent ce collectif voici ce qu'il
pense toujours des rythmes scolaires
c'est très fort un milliard elle va
coûter au pays
si vous feriez en plus la garderie et si
vous faites quelque chose de la coûté 2
milliards dont 80 et 2 milliards on n'a
pas les moyens aujourd'hui avec la
baisse des moyens à la baisse des
dépenses publiques de soutenir une
réforme en plus qui n'a absolument pas
fait ses preuves
nous demanderons de toute façon
la suspension de cette réforme soit sous
la forme d'un moratoire soit sous la
forme d'une appelle le libre choix
les maires envie d'y aller on le on leur
demandera sinon on propose en général
obliger à mr apprendre à prendre des
risques et à engager sa responsabilité
sans lui donner les moyens
sans lui donner les effectifs et sans
lui donner en plus le contenu
pédagogique parce que vraiment il y
aurait eu un contenu pédagogique
homologué par éducation sans attaquer m
c'est à nous de d'inventer maintenant
alors bon mois la limite j'ai des
tablettes g9 rassurer siens assez
importante mais le maire qui connaît pas
l'éducation nationale je sais pas qui
était un médecin
qu'est ce que vous les équidés qui se
mettent à créer du contenu pédagogique
donc c'est insensé cette réforme c'est
insensé cette réforme dont les s'est
adjugé national acquis abordé par le
maire d'elancourt non ce n'est pas une
réponse une réformation c'est du tout
parce que ce qui est dit là c'est une
partie des choses et cette partie c'est
justement celles qui relèvent de la
compétence des collectivités
territoriales c'est quelle est l'offre
perry éducatif périscolaire au sein
d'une commune ou d'une intercommunalité
donc en effet peut-être des questions à
trancher au niveau national autant un
terme à la glace à une politique
d'accompagnement de l'état plus global
qui irait de la crèche finalement
jusqu'aux adolescents
tant qu'on a faites sont sans problème
et des réformes à la carte si par
exemple c'est ce qui a été évoqué par le
maire d'elancourt les communes qui
veulent ok les communes qui ne veulent
pas alors ensuite justement elles ont
déjà la compétence de diriger leur
politique dans ce secteur même moi je
crois vraiment que ça appelle plutôt une
réflexion nationale sur les politiques
d'accompagnement de l'état et par
exemple de la cnaf sur les activités
proposées dans les territoires de type
encadrement large périscolaire
comprenant depuis la crèche aux ados
revanche que se tient à dire c'est que
non il ya autre chose s'il faut voir
c'est quand on est du côté éducation
ce que je constate moi c'est qu'on a
tout un sujet sur le fait que les élèves
vont être présents en classe 5 matinées
semaine c'est ce qu'ils défendent en
éducation nationale pour le voilà mais
moi c'est plutôt mon sujet c'est pour ça
que j'ai effectivement ce qui dépend
même pas vous est aujourd'hui toutes les
communes ont décidé de s'y plier
il n'y a pas de résistance à nous non
sur des écoles dans l'essonne par
exemple dans la commune de nicolas
dupont aignan l'a déjà annoncé il l'a
déjà commencé à mettre en place des
cadenas sur certaines grilles d'école
pour signifier que ce serait fermé
mercredi matin les enseignants ne
pourront pas rentrer mais les âges à
l'origine et donc voilà et j'ai deux
choses à dire et d'ailleurs je voulais
je le fais depuis depuis la pré rentrée
là c'est salué la responsabilité des
acteurs dans le département et notamment
les mères on laisse penser beaucoup vu
je connais bien le maire d'elancourt
comme d'autres mais au delà des prises
de position en gardant qu'une l'ensemble
des responsables eh bien vous fasse
en attendant ils ont pris leurs
responsabilités on m'a dit bien des fois
nous ne prendrons pas en otage les
enfants de notre commune même si on est
contre la réforme en tout cas la règle
allez on laisse les en a bien fait la
distinction entre et depuis je deuxième
chose à dire qui est plutôt d'ordre plus
personnel et venant en même temps de
quelqu'un qui est responsable dans
l'éducation nationale
je trouve que l'image d'un cadenas donc
de la fermeture sur une école dans un
contexte qui est discutable rationalise
à bhl et sur lequel l'histoire n'est pas
encore totalement écrite
c'est une image que la république
peut pas la réforme pas forcément
évidente à mettre en place sur le
terrain c'est ce que nous a confié
également le recteur de l'académie de
versailles que nous avons rencontré
cette semaine ce n'était pas facile pour
les communes qui avaient des
organisations importante d'activités
extrascolaires le mercredi matin qu'ils
avaient une autre médiation pour
accueillir les élèves de restructurer
leur dispositif puisque nous étions les
invités à l'école mercredi matin donc
elles ont plutôt fait preuve de très
très bonnes volontés elles ont souhaité
la plus pour la plupart avoir d'activité
péri éducatives dans le domaine sportif
culturel et autres qui s'articule avec
l'enseignement désormais organisés sur
un temps un peu différent et un peu
décompressé pour les élèves puissent
mieux apprendre la réforme des rythmes
scolaires est là elle est en place il y
aura par la suite des points d'étape des
bilans qui seront faits pour au moins
remonté son terrain concrètement comment
ça se passe pour que ça fonctionne faut
que ce soit efficace
oui absolument voir déjà je confirme les
propos qu'on vient d'entendre je suis
allé aux essarts-le-roi je suis allée
saint germain est allé aux mureaux est
allé à achères dans la vraie vie de tous
les jours
en effet on a vu des jo s'activer pour
proposer des scénarios tout de suite
donc aux essarts par exemple à l'heure
de fin c'est un système tournant avec
1h30 de tape alors de fin j'ai assisté à
la prise en charge déjà efficace par les
animateurs avec les enseignants qui
connaissait parfaitement le dispositif
voilà donc pour l'occasion de revenir
sur le bilan nécessairement on va
activer une évaluation pourquoi
nécessairement parce que il faut
rappeler que presque la moitié des
communes du département a déposé un
projet du captif territoriale et pour
une part et les hauts faits parce que
ils expérimentent quelque chose ils
dérogent notamment il ya tous ceux qui
dérogent au rythme initial du décret
peyo et guy of une après midi contes
hier de d'activité par semaine cela on
les évaluera nécessairement avec eux
deuxième point nous avons appelé tous
les élus qu'ils aient de l'expérience ou
pas depuis un an ou qu'ils démarrent à
continuer un comité de suivi localement
au calme nous rendrons et puis enfin au
plan départemental en un bon comité de
suivi avec des représentants de tous les
partenaires
nous maintiendrons et nous continuerons
éditer des fiches d'évaluation pour
essayer de guider la démarche dans les
communes et concernant les rythmes
scolaires sur notre antenne ce mardi
soir le 7-8 société présentée par
catherine je l'attends qui fait sa
rentrée
les différents intervenants qui
débattront de du bien fondé ou non de
cette réforme la rentrée scolaire 300
2624 élèves dans le département des
yvelines c'est plus que l'année dernière
voyez la cautionner ça pousse donc je
veux toujours plaisir à venir sur votre
plateau pour depuis quelques années au
moins dire que voilà on est en évolution
démographique continue positive
donc on ouvre des classes légèrement
positive aux des classes on le fait
traditionnellement avant que les
scolaires ne commence puis là comme vous
l'avez constaté au continue d'ouvrir des
classes plus comprendre qu'on enferme
les ajustements soient en cours j'ai
ouvert une quinzaine de classes pour un
retrait du jour et puis je continue là
parce qu'il ya quelques cars encore dans
le département on va parler des
effectifs parce qu'il faut des
enseignants derrière ces classes ce sera
dans un instant tout d'abord sur les
moyens qui sont alloués à l'éducation on
parle là de moyens supplémentaires avec
la mise en place des règles plus les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire cela
concerne la trappe et mes romans que la
jolie aussi par exemple pourquoi
ouais c'est un vrai enjeu pour le
département des yvelines parce qu'on a
la moitié des nouvelles éducation
prioritaire de toute l'académie de
versailles
alors en quoi ça consiste on renforce au
maximum comme on dit le travail des
enseignants ont pour faire réussir
davantage les élèves pour faire ça on
les décharges davantage
on leur permet une formation qui va
jusqu'à neuf jours dans l'année
et puis on réorganise l'ensemble des
dispositifs des projets des réseaux
notamment alors s'arrête plus est ce que
ça va permettre en tout cas de sortir de
ce mauvais classement pour la france
dans le système pénal niveau
d'évaluation des élèves de 15 ans de 65
pays et la france y figure à la 25e
place le directeur allemand de
l'éducation est de l'organisation de
coopération et de développement
économiques ocde pour pour faire simple
dit que l'école française est la plus
inégalitaire au monde
oui ça fait un moment que ça dure on dit
récemment mais ça c'est le résultat
pour autant il faut pas oublier tous les
efforts qui sont faits est ce qu'on
jugule malgré tout du point de vue des
inégalités la l'espoir qu'on a avec les
nouveaux dispositifs de ces dernières
années qui en fait remonter au delà de
2010 2012 certaines choses ont été sciés
dans les années 90 dans l'éducation
prière prioritaire ce qu'on espère c'est
vraiment appuyé là où on sait qu'on a du
résultat supplémentaire
les mises en groupes plus petits sont
les dispositifs plus de maîtres queux de
classe dans certaines écoles
la prise en charge beaucoup plus tôt et
manière appropriée des moins de 3 ans et
puis un certain nombre d'autres facteurs
qui vont faire que les enseignants vont
y rester un peu plus longtemps
espère-t-on moins de turnover
et puis qu'on acquiert les fondamentaux
de manière plus efficace
donc voilà c'est pas du jour au
lendemain que peut-être pisa maître
alain strabon la france au top mais la
conscience de ce problème depuis grandi
les efforts historiques qui sont faits
doivent nous permettre de gagner du
terrain
alors ça passe bien évidemment par aussi
un nombre suffisant de d'enseignants et
puis des enseignants bien formés parce
que là aussi c'est même encore plus
important que le nombre encore faut-il
la qualité il ya des nouveaux
professeurs et qui sont arrivés dans le
département ils ont vécu eux aussi leur
premier jour de classe
on va retrouver emmanuel c'est une
enseignante à montigny le bretonneux
vous l'avez déjà découvert si vous nous
suiviez hier sur cette antenne en train
de préparer à sa classe aujourd'hui elle
était face aux élèves
elle fait bilan la rentrée scolaire a
sonné ce matin ils étaient 300 2624
enfants à retrouver les bancs de l'école
dans les départements un grand jour pour
tous les écoliers mais aussi pour
emmanuel de l'orge
elle entame sa première année en tant
que professeur des écoles à
l'établissement marie noëlle de matinée
ce qu'elles valent étude où l'on passe
ce soir d'accord et clara tu peux
t'asseoir ya le plan castle show tableau
emmanuel aura à sa charge 25 élèves de
cm2 cette année elle est encore
stagiaire son temps sera répartie entre
l'enseignement et une formation
universitaire le reste de la semaine les
enfants auront classe avec valérie lopez
la directrice donc je suis quand même en
école mal de l'or je prends ma suite
jeudi et vendredi et on fera un mercredi
sur deux aujourd'hui elle donne cours
exceptionnellement à 2 et léna une
assistante de vie scolaire les épaulera
également au quotidien
elle aura à sa charge deux enfants avec
un handicap léger
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment très bien que
qui est quelqu'un pour les accompagner
pour les aider à écrire à comprendre des
choses pour voir pour qu'il puisse
participer vraiment dans la classe comme
les autres ce matin la classe a fait
connaissance en premier échange réussi
pour emmanuel c'est le début d'une
carrière synonyme de passion ce que
j'aime dans ce métier c'est vraiment le
contact avec les enfants j'aime leur
spontanéité ils sont enfin je les trouve
assez motivés par rapport on va dire aux
plus grands souvent qu'ils sont au
collège blessé voilà sinon j'aimais
plein de choses dans la vie j'aime et
tout ce qui ce qui touche à la
psychologie
mais les langues étrangères j'aimais la
lecture voilà j'adorais aussi les
enfants bien sûr et j'ai trouvé que ce
métier a regroupé un petit peu tout le
baptême du feu est passé et manivelle
entame aujourd'hui sa vie d'enseignante
on ne fuiront vient de voir une
enseignante qui se dit elle même
passionnée où on entend aussi souvent
pointé du doigt l'éducation nationale
parce que les enseignants ne sont pas
assez formés à la gestion de classe là
aussi c'est un constat qui fait par
l'eau c'est d'eux dont on parlait tout à
l'heure avec ce classement pisa est ce
qu'un enseignement un encadrement
particulier pour ces pour ces
enseignants on leur apprend à gérer la
passion ne fait pas tout il faut savoir
transmettre aussi son savoir mais tout à
fait donc déjà dire qu'ils sont 340
comme emmanuel dans le département des
yvelines et ils sont 340 justement avec
une nouvelle approche puisque c'est la
mise en place des écoles supérieures de
du professeur et de l'éducation donc à
partir de sites universitaires en effet
à mi temps comment le retour du ils vont
être pris en charge sur dans ses écoles
dans ses sites universitaires et à mi
temps ils sont en classe donc on espère
en effet qu'un aller retour sur la
question de la gestion de classe
ils sont près à mi temps en classe ils
vont en tirer des enseignements
ils vont poser des questions et on sera
là pour leur répondre à la fois avec des
universitaires qui leur donneront un
master à l'arrivée de cette année et en
même temps des enseignants des
inspecteurs qui les encadreront qui font
les allées et venues entre le terrain
comme on dit éliminer la cité donc on a
peu d'espoir d'améliorer cette tâche à
rejouer un dernier mot sur sur les
effectifs juste dans les syndicats dans
les yvelines qui disent que la balance
est déficitaire en matière de postes
par exemple il n'y avait pas assez de
volontaires en tout cas de deux
candidats sur les différents concours du
coup il n'y a pas à cette professeure et
des classes sont surchargées
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui ouais
c'est la rentrée
donc on va être positif pour opérer une
réalité tout de même il a présenté
différemment
la réalité je suis le président du jury
du concours académique de recrutement
des profs d'école donc je veux bien
placé depuis six ans maintenant pour
pourvoir les évolutions en effet tout
montre qu'on a un problème notamment
pour l'académie de versailles à recruter
des enseignants continuent de nos fort
besoin pour autant si les concours
antérieur c'est qu'on en a eu 2 cette
année les concours ancienne formule ne
nous permettait pas d'avoir en effet
autant de personnes que deux places au
concours
ce à quoi on assiste c'est que sur le
concours qui donne les stagiaires comme
emmanuel on a eu une recrudescence
importante de candidats ils sont plus
jeunes ils sont étudiants et donc on a
même pu compenser les places perdues au
concours ancienne formule
passé le premier point et le second
c'est quand on fait le tour des
universités notre ressort au sein de
l'espèce cette école on s'aperçoit comme
m1 qui destine aux concours en fin de
première année on a 30 % d'étudiants de
plus cette année
donc voilà petit à petit j'espère va
regagner lens pour une attraction pour
le coup pour la profession donc faut
donner une image positive c'est très
bien pour ses reportages tentorio la
rentrée se passe bien pour moins
toujours restituer dans cette rentrée
c'est un ordre
merci d'être venus en ce 2 septembre
jour de rentrée
quant à nous on va encore parler
d'éducation à présent on va se pencher
sur les compétences du département en la
matière le président du conseil général
des yvelines pierre bédier verrait d'un
bon oeil que la compétence des lycées
soit transférée de la région au
département les explications c'est avec
quatre nuls à temps en déplacement dans
ce nouveau collège d'achères dans le
nord du département le président du
conseil général pierre bédier vient
symboliquement signalé une fin celle des
collèges de plus de 1000 élèves
il n'y en a plus alors qu'ils étaient 18
il y a trente ans ça voulait dire des
classes surchargées des équipements avec
des préfabriqués dans les cours et c'est
donc ça y est c'est fini on aura mis 30
ans grâce à la décentralisation
c'est d'ailleurs la décentralisation qui
a réparti les compétences d'organisation
aux communes la charge des écoles au
département les collèges et aux régions
lycée une situation qui ne convient plus
au président du conseil général lui
verrait d'un bon oeil que cette
compétence reviennent au département et
il ne prend pas de détour pour le dire
j'appelle de mes voeux que les lycées
dépendant des départements ils seront
mieux gérer je pense que tous les
conseillers régionaux géré mal et que
c'est pas parce qu'il est socialiste qui
german c'est parce que ça n'est pas la
bonne échelle on sait pas qui est
responsable et si vous allez voir un
conseiller régional il peut vous
répondra ne sais pas moi le responsable
c'est ma chaîne dans un autre
département et là vous ne connaissez pas
alors que votre conseiller général quand
vous allez le voir il peux pas vous dire
combien je vous ai pas dans mon
département
il est obligé de prendre en compte comme
le maire ce qu'on vous dit ce que nous
souhaitons nous en tant que
professionnel de ligue nationale en tant
que recteur c'est qu' on puisse assurer
au maximum les les continuités et les
articulations et donc d'avoir
effectivement une collectivité en sept
ans responsable unique aux activités
responsables segment c'est toujours très
positif parce que ça permet
effectivement de trouver les vrais
continuité et on construit pas de la
même manière cantona écoles et collèges
ensemble ou collèges et lycées en
responsabilité pour le conseil général
cela permettrait également que les
collèges et les lycées soit au même
niveau en termes d'équipements
numériques
tous les collèges du département
bénéficie de cet outil six
établissements testent déjà les
tablettes numériques les collèges sont
largement en avance sur les lycées
estime pierre bellier
une façon aussi pour le président du
département de défendre l'institution
conseil général alors qu'il y a quelques
mois le gouvernement a annoncé sa
volonté de les supprimer la rentrée
c'est aussi au conseil régional d'île de
france et l'ambiance y est plutôt tendue
entre le président socialiste jean paul
huchon est sa principale opposante ump
valérie pécresse cette dernière parle
d'un désengagement massif de la région
dans l'entretien et la création des
lycées reportage candidate déjà en
campagne pour les prochaines régionales
valérie pécresse chef de file de
l'opposition ump lancent une nouvelle
polémique
elle accuse jean paul huchon de réduire
ses investissements en faveur des lycées
exemple selon elle la dépense par
établissements franciliens est passé de
1330 euros à 875 euros entre 2008 et
dans la région la plus inégalitaire pour
la jeunesse
ce jean paul huchon a fait le choix de
baisser drastiquement les budgets des
lycées s'il ya qu un seul chiffre à
retenir en 2010 il y avait une opération
de rénovation construction sur deux qui
est en retard et bien quatre ans plus
tard ces deux opérations sur 3,50 de
chantier en retard il c'est hallucinant
de voir l'inertie de la région et de
pointer dans les yvelines cet
établissement en sureffectif et 21
chantiers en retard de maurepas attrape
en passant par montigny le bretonneux
compétence exclusive des régions les
lycées sont au nombre de 4 172 en
ile-de-france la majorité socialiste et
dit vouloir est consacré plus de 2
milliards pour la construction et la
rénovation sur la période 2012 à 2022 et
balaye les accusations de sa rivale on
peut critiquer tel ou tel chose que nous
faisons mais encore faut-il ne pas
mentir éhontément et c'est ce qu'elle
fait et puis en plus en faisant de
grosses erreurs si elles étaient plus
souvent pour ces régionales elle lui
aurait peut-être passer les dossiers les
décisions je crois qu'on peut dire
maintenant que dans la plupart des
lycées il ya maintenant un niveau
d'équipement
équipant il y compris informatique qui
est devenu très honorable pour ne pas
dire plus bataille de chiffres et
petites phrases avant que ne commence la
campagne des régionales ce sera a priori
en décembre 2015 à soit un report de
plusieurs mois sur le calendrier
électoral mais qui doit encore être
validée par le sénat
tourisme a présenté la saison estivale
qui n'a pas été à la hauteur des
attentes faute à une météo capricieuse
comment les sites yvelinois ont réussi
ou non à sortir leur épingle du jeu de
thoiry à versailles en passant par saint
quentin en yvelines évidemment florane
parfait et william l
on l'a plutôt fait dans la région
parisienne reste cher paris il a fallu
attendre la rentrée scolaire pour enfin
profiter du beau temps
la météo capricieuse a pesé sur le
tourisme seuls 43% des professionnels
jugent bonne l'activité touristique de
cet été ici à la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines on dispose de
multiples installations pour les
activités sportives mais cela n'a pas
suffit pour conserver une bonne
fréquentation pendant l'été jusqu'au
mois de juin on a on a eu une base de
loisirs remplie
fidèle à elle-même par contre à partir
de juillet c'est la catastrophe sur les
activités comme pour la piscine
puisqu'on est à peu près à 40 % de la
fréquentation habituelle avec seulement
dix sept mille entrées enregistrées en
juillet août pour la piscine à vagues
c'est 50 % de moins qu'en 2013 même
constat à thoiry où la pluie a aussi
découragé les amoureux de la nature
on a perdu 6 ou 7% à thouaré cette année
du fait de la météo en juillet et en
août mais juillet ou conséquence de ce
temps maussade l'affluence dans les
musées du département qui eux ont
enregistré des chiffres satisfaisants
par rapport à 2013 si on prend le
château de versailles forcément c'est
différent du reste sont avant tout des
touristes étrangers
vous prenez mes sites touristiques du
département ce absolument linverse c'est
85 % des franciliens évident
à la saison n'est pas encore finie
nombreux professionnels croit on l'été
indien a annoncé à la rentrée pour
atteindre leurs prévisions
je vous rappelle l'information du jour
c'est la rentrée scolaire 300 2624
élèves donc département cette année des
problématiques de rythmes scolaires ou
encore d' accompagnement renforcé des
élèves à gérer l'une des nouveautés pour
cette rentrée c'est la mise en place des
règles plus les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire 2.0 nouvelle version on
écoute à ce sujet le recteur de
versailles le rectangle et les
professeurs vont avoir un temps de
service allégé pour pouvoir travailler
entre eux entre l'école et collège pour
travailler sur des projets propres à
l'école pour au collège ils vont voir
une formation renforcée pour
effectivement encore une fois fluidifier
ce qu'on appelle les parcours scolaires
et si vous n'étiez pas avec nous au
début de cette édition l'entretien avec
l'inspecteur de l'académie qui s est
déroulée au tout début du journal est à
revoir dès à présent en replay sur notre
site internet ainsi que l'ensemble des
reportages de cette édition le journal
qui revient à demain toujours en direct
à 18h pour une nouvelle édition
excellente soirée sur notre antenne
c'est avec 4 x de la tow pour la reprise
du 7-8 société consacrée aux rythmes
scolaires